اما عن النوويه فبعد فتره ليست بطويله
سيتمكن النظام الايراني من الحصول على
سلاح النووي واسرائيل تهدد بعمل عسكري كحل
اخير لردع قدرات طهران النوويه وفقه ما
كشفته صحيفه دي اكسبريس البريطانيه طهران
تعملوا على تخصيب مخزوناتها من اليورانيوم
كي تصل الى عتبه 90% وهو المستوى المطلوب
لانشاء راس حربي نووي يمكن وضعه في صاروخ
باليسي تقول هنا الصحيفه البريطانيه
الوصول مشاهدينا الى سلاح النوويه يستغرق
ثمانيه عشر شهرا لانشاء نظام توصيل فعال
وايران قضت معظم تلك المده وامامها فقط
اسابيع وافقه خبراء غربيين الامر الذي
سيجبر الغرب واللاعبين الاقليميين على
اعاده تقييم خياراتهم تجاه طاهره حتى الان
قام النظام الايراني بتخصيب 75 كيلوغرام
من اليورانيوم حتى اي حصل الى حدود ال 60
بالمئه مما يكفي طبعا لصنع قنبله نوويه
ولتحييد قدرات ايران النوويه هددت اسرائيل
مشاهدينا بانها ستشن عملا عسكريا كحل اخير
ضد طهران حتى ولو قامت به بمفردها من دون
طعم طبعا دعم الحلفاء الضربات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه يجب ان تنفذ قريبا نظرا لقرب
تواصل طهران الى العتبه النوويه حيث يمكن
لايران دفن هذه المواد على عمق 60 متر تحت
الارض في مصنع فوردو للتخصيب بالقرب كما
اشار طبعا الصحيفه الامريكيه ومن خلال
تسليح برنامجها النووي تعتقد طهران بانها
ستعزز قواتها الاقليميه والدوليه لفرض
شروطها دوليا مما يصعب طبعا الاطاحه او
تغيير النظام الاراني